consider the similarities between Laura
Palmer and Marilyn Monroe both blonde
most of the time they both have bubbly
exteriors that mask inner struggles
which each accounted in their secret
diaries and their tragic premature
deaths each had a profound ripple effect
this is not a coincidence the year was
1989 David Lynch was an undeniable star
just two years after his Oscar
nomination for blue velvet Lynch was an
established creative force despite that
if you would trust a budding art or with
the television series I don't know that
much about TV and about ratings which is
where more frost comes in by 1989 mark
frost was an established fiction and
television writer between Lynch's
cultural cachet and Frost's experience
they were uniquely suited to tag team on
this eccentric endeavor on earth you are
witnessing a front three-quarter view of
two adults sharing a tender moment the
pair's first project was a feature film
script inspired by an paid summer's
goddess The Secret Lives of Marilyn
Monroe the book focused on Maryland's
untimely demise and the mysterious
circumstances surrounding her death
sound familiar
Lynch and frost soon realized the
stories many loose threads though
endlessly fascinating could never be
confirmed in the studio dropped the
project so the two took the mystery and
created the fictional story of Laura
Palmer whose murder is the focal point
of Twin Peaks the parent ever finished
the script for the Munro project but
rumor has it the script posits that
Marilyn was murdered we'll never know
who Lynch and frost fingered for the
culprit could it have been Bob